[Music]
if disney truly thinks we need almost 90
seconds of recapping at the beginning of
every episode to help the new episode
make sense i really have to ask why they
didn't just release this as a movie get
the back to time
ah the back to tank i should have
guessed does all the heavy lifting so
the writers don't have to deal with the
consequences of physically freaking up
the protagonist and the audience doesn't
have to give a [ __ ] when they see
someone injured also this all seems a
bit over dramatic doesn't this franchise
usually just have people recuperating on
an uncomfortable looking bed in sickbay
don't
expecting someone who has just woken up
in a vat of liquid not to freak out
tv show completely skips obi-wan losing
a shirt with tala for leaving leia
behind and allowing her to be kidnapped
by the bad guys she should be [ __ ]
furious right now we don't even see the
mildest of forced jokings you can't keep
me here my father is a senator writers
think that the leia we all know and love
would be throwing around this do you
know who my father is cliche i am a
princess of alderaan kids she knows
everything telling secrets to a child
ever you have no idea what the empire is
capable of of course rogue knows what
the empire is capable of does obi-wan
think he's doing here digging for
fossils i could be the most ignorant
[ __ ] i've heard out of anyone in the
star wars universe and it came from
obi-wan now unfortunately rogan sets him
straight but unfortunately that just
means this was a setup to force fetus
rokin's motivations great but why at the
expense of obi-wan what the [ __ ] is this
show doing dobby want kenobi i had a
wife once but also
skip look if you want my help
you got it obi-wan being a dick works so
that's it
fortress inquisitorious i don't care if
it's pulled from a comic or video game
or whatever fortress inquisitorius still
follows the make it sound vaguely latin
school of naming things and it sounds
dumb as heck there i said it dumb as
heck inquisite me if you must it's
impenetrable wade it will of course
proved to be extremely penetrable truth
is nobody knows what it looks like so
what is the point of this fancy hologram
if it has zero information to share it's
not even red i don't see any shields
that's because no one would be stupid
enough to attack them yes but the only
thing dumber than that is not equipping
the place with shields because you
assume no one is dumb enough to attack
it we need to find a way inside well
we're not soldiers those feeders are for
hauling sewage she's 10 years old
thinking that the age of the child
you're rescuing will change the core
function of your speeders or the ability
of those riding them also we need a
dirty jobs episode on how they're
hauling sewage in these things because
right now i'm guessing the back seat and
that's definitely a sin i can get you
inside and i can get you access is your
cover still intact
we'll find out soon enough i know they
have limited options but this is not a
plan this is like me pulling out a 10
year old condom and assuming it won't
immediately explode my best friend and i
play a game of kerspunk curse punk is a
game where we fill a condom with jello
and then throw it at each other until it
bursts and then the person who threw it
gets to shout curse punk wait what do
you use condoms for wasting time yep the
past is a hard thing to forget and you
just need time that's all yes i hear the
first 10 years post failing to prevent
the murder of all your jedi friends and
younglings is all about denial and it's
the following tin where the real healing
starts
i need to find out where they are i
can't say for sure that the writers
momentarily thought it would be awesome
if this episode had riva use her
cool-looking lightsaber and a showdown
with obi-wan i can confirm they chose to
have her character interrogate a child
for most of the episode instead thinking
that this show needed the largest and
coolest version of that thing at the
airport that lets the tsa agent get a
good look at your package and yes
whichever package you're thinking of i'm
talking about the other one perhaps i
should just inform the grand inquisitor
of your insolence allowing your
vigilance to be confused with insolence
by an abundance of confidence all right
i'm inside the system
here we go just to recap here the
impenetrable fortress consists of a wide
open hangar and one incompetent guard
that doesn't feel the need to challenge
a suspicious visitor it's about as
impenetrable as a ten-year-old condom
filled with jell-o being thrown you get
the idea obi-pron kenobi ben
i'm overriding an entry port oh lisa
wasn't a [ __ ] exhaust port this time
nope that's not a sin removal that's me
adding an extra sin for the original
trilogy obi-wan episode 4 misses the
opportunity to pull a star wars episode
4 by not disguising obi-wan as a
stormtrooper also why doesn't he
disguise himself as a stormtrooper
[Music]
when the [ __ ] was lola's plan here
adorable her to death
nobody within your shot including this
[ __ ] guy who we know heard her does
[ __ ] all about this
giving directions like this indoors a
galaxy far far away with laser swords
faster than light travel planet killing
space stations but no concept of 360
degree cameras and why would destroyed
look through the windows and not just
open the door and how is it supervisor
putting up with this kind of laziness
either everyone stepped out for lunch
while this was happening or the generic
evil officer here was a real dick to his
employees and they're all quite happy to
go about their work to the tune of him
getting his ass kicked ben
did you hear that
over there let's go good to know that
the stormtroopers have a pre-agreed
hierarchy when it comes to suspicious
noises and that generic thuds in the
distance rank above unexplained radio
comms i think i just found the secure
sector
because the [ __ ] door decals are red
the only thing dumber than obi-wan
assuming this is the fact that he's
right this place isn't a fortress it's a
tune thinking your jedi will increase in
value if you don't take them out of the
packaging what are you doing the same
thing i do to anyone who doesn't embrace
the empire not giving the person you're
about to encase in amber the courtesy of
a clear and honest answer wait no not
giving the viewer the courtesy of a
clear and honest answer because i'm just
assuming you're doing to her what we
just saw obi-wan looking at but for all
we know this device could be for root
canals or making cotton candy this is
your last chance leia except we all know
it isn't the music the dialogue the
acting everything is supposed to make me
feel some kind of suspense but that's a
tall order when i know disney thankfully
would never show a child being tortured
and we already know leia survives this
tala i need a distraction
just do it now this request is so vague
that it raises a serious question about
how tala managed to come up with the
appropriate distraction she could have
just stood on the desk and began singing
jiggle jiggle and i'm sure everyone in
the room would have been distracted but
it would have been the least bit helpful
for leia's situation unless of course
you're lying riva's rightfully skeptical
but wastes a bunch of time on questions
instead of immediately doing the thing
where she force pulls the information
out of your mind i guess it would have
been convenient for her but inconvenient
for the plot
[Music]
yes
finally the kid is back the return of
the mother forcing jedi but the writers
made his way till episode 4. so
apparently the secret droid speed is set
to slightly slower than a child like
most of the bad guys in this show it's
official stormtrooper helmets cause more
harm than good tala slaps this guy in
the head and it completely takes him out
of the game beginning to wonder if
they're actually just plastic shells
with an array of spikes on the inside
it's not just that this works it's also
that despite his dip in the ocean
earlier he hasn't been tracking water
all over the base so the real sin is
that none of the water in this episode
is working properly i want to be shut
down
now
i want your character to do more than
just walk around being angry all the
time but we don't always get what we
want
there's no
he is not
oh my goodness he's he's hiding her
under a [ __ ] overcoat look at her
little red boots walking alongside him
oh my she peeks out and none of these
dozens of people noticed this discount
vincent adultman just walking around
this is how scooby doo would have
[ __ ] escaped what is going on here
every stormtrooper in the hangar has
their blaster trained on these three and
this guy just cuts through the situation
like pardon me excuses me are late for a
meeting
i'll admit it i laughed when tala shot
the little mouse droid but considering
the tone of the rest of this episode i
have no idea if this was a joke or if
the little guy actually posed a threat
come on show pick a path destroy them
fifth brother says this while also not
doing any destroying
wait obi-wan episode ends with riva
staring at obi-wan on an escaping ship
cliche where's wade okay fine i'll go
watch all of star wars clone wars and
rebels so i can feel the impact of
wade's death better i'm sure he appears
somewhere in those 208 episodes right
right
what do you want to discuss now my
favorite color some hag trophy wife
needs new skin for a facelift or one of
them gets sick and they need a new heart
they take it from you
doesn't he realize that i am the
daughter of the fifth house of betazin
holder of the sacred chalice of reeks
you can't keep me here my father is a
senator you know there's lots of things
you expect in war carnage the sleepless
nights
but what they don't prepare you for
is the incessant use of fortunate sun
it's their base of operation so
probably got a command scenario training
facility remember the amenities now you
don't yell out of energy
i'm going to go across the street and
get you some orange
sherbert
i'm going to go across the street and
get you some orange sherbet this armor's
useless why do i even wear it i'll have
to tell my father first
that's okay right you said we're all on
the same side
[Music]
why aren't you a little ah how can you
look me in the eye and lie like that
yeah what are you in for
everything it makes sense path would
have people among us this is the way
[Music]
i'm sorry dave
i'm afraid i can't do that